The basic premise of any person being within
six degrees of relationship to each other
traces back to at least 1929, mentioned in
the short story “Chain-Links” from the
book Everything is Different, by Hungarian
author Frigyes Karinthy.
In the story, Karinthy was putting forth the
idea that, with advances in technology, despite
vast distances between people and the growing
world population, the world was actually shrinking
from an interconnectedness standpoint- a trend
that would no doubt only continue over time.
As such, a game is proposed in the story as
follows:
We should select any person from the 1.5 billion
inhabitants of the Earth – anyone, anywhere
at all.
He bet us that, using no more than five individuals,
one of whom is a personal acquaintance, he
could contact the selected individual using
nothing except the network of personal acquaintances.
Although a few toyed with this general idea
(though not necessarily six degrees specifically)
over the following decades when studying network
theory- most notably Stanley Milgram in his
famous “Small-World Experiment“- the specific
idea of a supposed maximum of six degrees
of separation between everyone on Earth didn’t
really enter into popular culture until John
Guare incorporated it into his play, Six Degrees
of Separation, in 1990.
This was later made into a 1993 film starring
Will Smith, Stockard Channing, and Donald
Sutherland.
(Ironically, Donald Sutherland for a time
held the crown as the actual most interconnected
actor, as we’ll get into shortly.)
This all brings us around to Kevin Bacon and
a trio of college students with nothing better
to do owing to a snow storm in 1994.
The students in question, Craig Fass, Mike
Ginelli and Brian Turtle of Albright College
in Reading, PA, were watching Footloose on
TV.
After it ended, the 1994 The Air Up There
either came on or was being advertised.
The three naturally noticed Bacon in both
and began to discuss the amazing number of
movies Kevin Bacon had starred in and with
whom he worked.
Inspired, they came up with a game in which
someone would mention a random actor or actress’
name and they would try to figure out how
to connect that person to Bacon in six degrees
or fewer.
For example: Julia Louis-Dreyfus is connected
to Kevin Bacon by two degrees, as Bacon worked
with Wayne Knight on JFK and Knight also played
Newman on Seinfeld, in which Louis-Dreyfus
was Elaine Benes.
She can also be connected in two degrees via
the fact that she and Dianne Weist appeared
together in Hannah and Her Sisters.
Diane Wiest, of course, appeared with Kevin
Bacon in Footloose.
So how did this go from college party game
to one known the world over?
This is thanks, in part, to John Stewart and
his aptly named talk show, The Jon Stewart
Show (1993-1995).
The students wrote Stewart about their game
and, thinking it would make good fodder for
his show, they were invited to appear on The
Jon Stewart Show to talk about it.
They also ultimately appeared on the The Howard
Stern Show with Kevin Bacon himself; the game
spread far and wide from there.
As for Bacon, he at first didn’t care for
the game, but later came around.
In fact, by the time Fass, Turtle, and Ginelli
released the book, Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon
(1996), a companion to the Six Degrees of
Kevin Bacon board game, Bacon had such a change
of heart, he even wrote the book’s introduction.
Interestingly, while back in the day, we had
to rely on our memories to play the game and
find a celebrity’s Bacon number, today Google
will do the work for you.
Simply run a search with “Bacon number”
and the person’s name, and Google will tell
you the degrees of separation.
Just as helpfully, the Oracle of Bacon provides
the same service.
And speaking of the Oracle of Bacon, it turns
out they found you can’t actually connect
every actor in Hollywood to Bacon in under
six moves.
Further, Bacon isn’t even the most linkable
actor (though after analyzing over 800,000
actors and actresses in the history of film,
they did find Bacon was more linkable than
approximately 99% of actors in history).
As for the true most linkable actor in Hollywood,
this has varied over time, but has included
such people as Donald Sutherland, Dennis Hopper,
Rod Steiger, and, as of right now, Eric Roberts.
Bacon, interestingly enough, is currently
all the way down at number 455.
Rounding out the top 5 at present are #2 Michael
Madsen, #3 Samuel L. Jackson, #4 Danny Trejo,
and #5 Willem Dafoe.
One of the earliest popular social media sites
more or less resembling modern social site
networking (profiles, friends lists, status
updates through the social media site, etc.)
was SixDegrees.com, created all the way back
in 1997.
Founder Andrew Weinreich even noted they attempted
to make sharing pictures a centerpiece of
the service, but too few people used digital
cameras at the time, so, as he put it, “We
had board meetings where we would discuss
how to get people to send in their pictures
and scan them in.”
Only a few years later, widely adopted technology
would catch up to the idea.
At its peak, SixDegrees had nearly 4 million
members, ultimately selling for $125 million
to YouthStream Media Networks in 1999.
The site would be shut down just two years
later.
Not long after that, sites like Friendster,
MySpace, LinkedIn, XING, and Facebook would
pop up using more or less the same base model.
While Hollywood has the Six Degrees of Kevin
Bacon, the world of mathematics has Erdős
number, coined after famed mathematician Paul
Erdős, whose prolific work saw him publish
countless papers.
As such, a given mathematician’s Erdős
number is the distance said individual is
to Paul based on published papers (and the
authors listed), rather than movies and actors
as in the Six Degrees of Kevin Bacon.